>>Reto: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier and welcome to this
week in Android development for October 8th,
2012.
Comments from last week's episode suggest
that my broad Australian accent becomes entirely
impenetrable at the speed at which I've been
delivering "This Week in Android" updates.
Those of you who did understand me are probably
jealous of those who couldn't.
Nonetheless, in Google we're all about making
information universally accessible.
So this week's news is being post-processed
so that you can watch it played back at half-speed.
You're welcome.
You also told us that our new studio made
many of you uncomfortably aware of the emptiness
of the human condition and the transient insignificance
of our momentary human existence.
We briefly considered removing the backdrop
entirely, but it was decided that revealing
the constructs within the Googleplex might
be in violation of our employee NDA.
Ultimately we returned to our original projection
which makes it more readily believable that
we are projections of a ruling artificial
intelligence for whom humans represent little
more than a cheap source of energy.
Rest assured, this will be the sixth time
we've rebuilt our studio simulation, and we've
become exceedingly efficient at it.
In other Android news, Roman Nurik made over
travel booking and planning apps Kayak and
Trip Adviser on Android Design in Action.
Both apps have been updated with glamorous
new tablet layouts perfect for planning your
vacation from the comfort of your couch.
On Thursday the Developers of Kayak, Hipmonk,
and World Scope Webcams joined us in person
and over Hangout to inform us that they've
already thought of everything we said and
will have an update coming out in the next
couple of weeks that fixes everything.
L.A musician and cat-daddy Jackson Galaxy
will be dropping by our patients a little
later to see how they're doing.
On Friday, dynamic duo Koh Kim and Dan Galpin
were reunited for a jaundiced episode of the
Friday Games Review.
Early last Friday the wheels well and truly
fell off the well-oiled machine that is the
App Clinic.
We spent some time trying to debug the issue
before we moved through our surveillance footage
and managed to diagnose the likely source
of the problem.
We've got a fix in place, so don't worry.
We'll be back this Friday to review video
player apps.
And we're using the extra time to dig a little
deeper into the code that makes these apps
tick.
With no App Clinic patients to rebuild in
their own image, you might be worried that
Nick and Roman won't be dispensing their own
brand of design wisdom next Tuesday.
Fear not.
We're declaring this Tablet Week.
So tune in as we attempt to fuse Nick and
Roman into a single conjoined entity.
Join the creature we've dubbed NiMan on Tuesday
as it celebrates Tablet Week by sharing some
essential tablet design tips.
Then on Thursday we're inviting some successful
tablet developers to join us over Hangout
to share their tablet development challenges
and successes.
To help make every week Tablet Week, we've
also released a set of tablet quality guidelines
to help you build apps that delight and intrigue
the growing number of Android tablet users.
Dan and Koh will be back next Friday for another
installment of the Friday Games Review.
And of course you can tune in to our Developer
Office Hours on Wednesday, live from Downton
Abbey, Mountain View, Sidney, and Brazil.
For this week's US Office Hours we're trying
something new.
We're taking prerecorded video questions.
So record yourself asking a question and send
the video to our Google + page at +androiddevelopers.
As always, you can find all of last week's
shows in the schedule for this week at Google
Developers Live.
That's developers.google.com/live/Android.
You can also meet some of our developer advocates
live in the flesh when Nick Butcher presents
Modern Android UI's at DevFest Berlin, this
weekend, the 13th and 14th of October.
From the fully operational SeaBase Space Station.
This week in Android documentation we've expanded
the Android accessory protocol docs.
Which can now be found on source.Android.com.
We've also updated the dialogs guide to include
details for using dialog fragments.
And finally we have a new addition to Android
training with the new class detailing how
to save data within your apps.
Remember, persisting user data isn't just
a good idea, it's best practice.
In app releases and updates this week, we
saw the release of the Tomtom navigation suite.
A new release from Quicken Loans, My Quicken
Loans Mobile.
And Showtime Anytime now lets you watch your
favorite Showtime shows without your telebox.
That includes Dexter, whose companion app
will let you stay one step ahead of our favorite
psychotic serial killer.
That's all for this week in Android development.
We look forward to you joining us for our
many live shows this week.
And remember, no shoes, no shirt, and I still
get service.
My name is Reto Meier.
Thanks for watching.